this is a production of Cornell
University good ok
I'm Natalie I'm one of the organizers of
gpw and we're here obviously to talk
about interviews you have interviews
this afternoon
they are mock interviews but we're gonna
give you tips on how to actually do this
when you get into this grad school
application I'm the entire process but
you can see there's a lot of people at
the front of the room so I'm Natalie as
I said I'm an ecology and evolutionary
biology and all these nice folks are
going to introduce themselves also do
you wanna hi I'm Jenna me and I'm a
first year PhD student in soil and crop
sciences hi I'm Cass and I'm a second
year PhD student entomology I'm Jenny
I'm also a second year PhD student in
ecology and evolutionary biology I'm
Eugene I'm a second year PhD in so crop
science I'm Lizzy and I'm a third year
PhD student in ecology and evolutionary
biology
hi everyone probably introduce myself
several times all the time but I'm John
and I'm a third year in entomology thank
you all so all of these people are going
to be helping today we're gonna do some
practice of what it actually looks like
to interview and we're gonna hear about
what a real interview when you get to
grad school looks like so as a reminder
we've talked about the fact that you're
having interviews later today don't
stress too much about them their
practice you're not expected to know all
the information about the people that
you're interviewing with we're not
judging you in any way it's practice but
today we're going to talk about what can
help you in the next interviews that
you'll go to so as I said we're going
over a couple different things we're
explaining what actually happens in a
grad school interview how is it
different from other job interviews that
you might know of because it is it's a
very different thing than a job
interview will give you a tool from what
what you might use when you sit down at
the beginning of that interview and
you're like oh god what am I gonna do
what do I say how do I start we'll give
you one tool that you can use to start
and then we'll go over some
questions that you might want to ask in
interviews that's a big component of it
where people want you to ask questions
they want to get to know you they want
to make sure that you know what you need
to know for that program so you've heard
this many times already but we're here
as a resource we want you to ask
questions there's going to be time for
small group discussions today in this
workshop where you can ask anything you
want to know about interviewing maybe
other questions for the other workshops
because you'll get so much more
information okay so the cute picture I
thought basically we talked about an
interview often they're like 30 minutes
you get in there and you're like what am
I going to talk about now and you start
with introducing yourself that we're
calling an elevator pitch it's just a
quick sort of summary who are you what
do you do what are you excited about
then you're gonna go with this like
feedback back and forth you're gonna ask
questions they're gonna ask questions
what are those questions you'll find out
a little bit so when you're in that fat
discussion that interview where you're
assessing the program the school you're
also hearing out whether you're a good
match
with that person the big point of grad
school is you want to be happy you want
to make sure that you get along with a
person that you would work with and
that's the interview is the time where
you're face to face you can really
figure out do our personalities match do
I like this person could I work with
them so ask the questions that you need
to know to answer that and you also want
to know obviously about the science is
that research topic that you're
interested in really engaging and active
in that school in that program and in
that lab I know I'm going quickly
through this I'm a little excited some
of you might be excited also but we will
get into this
so I'm gonna turn it over to Toonami
who's going to talk about what faculty
expects so again I just thought I'd go
over really quickly the expectations
that faculty have from interviews which
is kind of this golden black box
question that I think we don't really
answer to at least I don't know the
answers to when I was in Japan for grad
school so we did the best thing that we
could think of and we went directly to
the faculty themselves and we sent out a
survey with these questions what do you
expect to be lab what do you expect them
to have done when they want to be in
your department what kind of skills or
personality traits you expect them to
display during interviews so
interestingly most faculty do not expect
you to have published papers in that
field or to have done any amount of
extensive research work what they do
expect and this is for faculty whose
labs your plank here they do expect you
to have read the research website and be
generally familiar with the area in
which they work and let's keep in mind
that this is for when you're actually
interviewing in grad school not for the
mock interviews that you will be having
later today afternoon so there's no need
to go over a faculty website we will be
in tripping woods today that's
unnecessary
but in the future that's a good tip so
this changes a little bit when we ask
them okay so what about someone who's
applying to be in your department but
who doesn't necessarily want to working
in that
how do your expectations change in that
case and so it's still consistent people
do expect that you've looked over their
website but you kind of know what's
going on in the field that you know the
latest kind of happenings in the field
but again nobody expects you have read
their papers nobody expects you to have
worked in that field but very important
again ask questions ask as many
questions as you can think of as as many
questions as you'd like people expect
you to be curious people expect you to
be interested in what their labs are
doing the programs are doing their
department is doing so that's key even
if you don't necessarily even if you're
not
really interested in that person's work
ask questions use that opportunity to
gain more knowledge so this is what
faculty had to say about what they
expect students interviewing with them
to be like so what skills can you
cultivate or what qualities can you
practice so that you can kind of deliver
on these expectations so from the same
survey these are kind of the broad areas
and the person gauges here are basically
the number of faculty who said they
would expect to see their students
display these qualities so what was
exciting to me here was that qualities
like intelligence excitement ability to
talk about your research interests these
were more important than things like
your GPA your grades and your chest
scores which I personally think is very
promising because as a graduate student
qualities like hard work and
perseverance and this comes out a little
bit the qualities like hard work and
perseverance I think are way more
important than there's academic
stereotype of someone who's sitting in
their ivory tower and becomes a movies
brilliant here's what's also interesting
is that a lot of faculty mentioned
contribution to diversity and creating
an inclusive environment as important
factors in hiring students and
interviewing students so that being said
a word of caution faculty may not always
understand the place you're coming from
and there could be instances in grad
school interviews where you may be asked
inappropriate questions or incorrect
assumptions may be made about you
there's a host of different ways to deal
with this and we could maybe talk about
this a little bit more during the
debriefing or the question answer
session but if you do have those
questions or concerns again feel free to
reach out we've all been there we've all
heard those questions and we're happy to
talk to you about our strategies those
situations so we emphasized the
importance of asking questions of being
curious so what we did and you should
see these in the handouts and knowledge
is passed on we've kind of compiled a
bunch of different questions that we
think are really useful when it comes to
introduce they
you should feel free to ask faculty
about say if you find yourself stressing
out you're panicking you can't really
think of anything off the top of your
head there's a list of questions ready
for you and to make it kind of easier to
process we broke them down into three
big areas questions about the program
questions about resources that are
available to you as a graduate student
and then questions about your social
life because this is an often overlooked
aspect of grad school because you're
gonna be spending two years or five
years or six years in this place and you
need to survive you need to have a
social network so you will find more
information on this in the handouts
really but very quickly so in terms of
the program you can definitely ask
faculty about their opinions about the
program how do we think it's changed
since they joined the program where do
you think it's heading you know what are
the strengths one of the weaknesses of
the program resources talk about
professional development opportunities
the students go to conferences the
students get trained on presentation
skills on grant writing skills how
active our students and leadership and
governance all of these are important
questions
how does funding work in the department
because different universities different
programs are very different funding
situations some people some departments
might expect you to teach for a certain
number of semesters or years some might
not so it's important to ask those
questions to know where your funding is
coming from and I think we're often
hesitant as graduate students because we
feel like we don't have that position of
power to ask these questions but it's
really important to do that same thing
about how long the students take to get
there each two year to get their masters
in this department and is that timeline
something you are personally comfortable
with social life I would say read the
room in terms of faculty interviews some
of these questions may be appropriate to
answering interviews some may not maybe
needs to be more appropriate during
social events or when you're talking to
graduate students but you can definitely
ask about the Graduate Student
Association how active is it how much
will you get to know about your cohort
about the people you are in this program
with what about lab meetings what the
lab atmosphere like what's
that must feel like what slap culture
like cost of living in that place how so
we like to be asked about funding
situation already
how far will they'll strike and take you
are you gonna be able to afford trend
are you going to be able to eat out once
number all of these are great questions
please don't hesitate to ask them and if
you have any other questions that you're
not sure if they're appropriate or not
once again talk to us we can figure it
out I'm gonna hand it back to Natalie so
we can get started on the elevator
pitches when you walk into the room this
might be the question you get it's not a
question it's just tell me about
yourself
and you might be like oh god like what
do I do with that and because all of us
feel that literally everyone standing in
front of the room has been in that
position we're gonna model what it might
look like for you we're actually going
to wait on passing out the tool until
after we model in the interest of time
but we're gonna turn it over to these
fine people just show you some examples
of what it might look like we've already
said this this is going to be okay you
can do it for me the hardest thing
you've been standing in front of this
room is relaxing enough not to just like
bounce all over the place so you're
gonna be fine you probably already know
that I need to tell myself that
sometimes maybe you do too so we're
gonna go over this in just a minute and
you'll get more information after we
practice but basically in an elevator
pitch like this you want to talk about
what you're doing now the present what
you've done that led you to that point
the past and what you want to do the
future you're going to get all of this
in a handout with more information about
what might fit into each of these
categories but it's important here you
notice like you're a person with a whole
history and really what they want to
know in that interview is what's your
history what do you want to do so your
future should connect to the experiences
that you
are doing right now and that you've done
previously
Anitra talked a lot about research
experiences and things that will help
you to sort of bolster your own past to
prepare you for grad school so this is
where you actually share it one-on-one
in person okay we're gonna come back to
that in a second first though I'm gonna
ask these people wonderful people to
model what an interview might look like
you Dean who introduced himself is going
to play the role of a professor watch
you think it'll be fun and then three of
these folks are gonna show you different
elevator pitches so I'm gonna call on
John first on Eugene and John are gonna
tell you give you this really really
quick elevator pitch it's gonna be one
minute
I'm gonna cut them off that's going to
be fun for everyone so okay so my name
is John and I'm like a student at
Cornell I'm like really like really
passionate about insects I'm doing my
major yeah my major in entomology and
it's it's great I like get to see bugs
and like I work with fruit flies and
they're like really cool cuz you know a
lot of like really cool genetic stuff
with them and but like what I'm really
actually interested in are their
microbes I think their microbes are
fascinating microbes do so many cool
things and insects like they're way way
cooler things that like I mean I just ah
you know they're these ants they're
amazing
like they farm I was wait what okay so
these ants they're amazing they farm
this fungus and a called leaf cutter
ants they're really cool I don't do any
research on them but like I took a class
and I learned a lot about them I'm like
sometimes I feel like I'm an expert
[Music]
hi hi I'm Cassie oh you know what sorry
I was actually out doing field work
yesterday I'm covered in paint
I'm so sorry um I'm working on
collecting bees right now in this like
weird way or using Feebles it's like
anyway um hi I'm Cass and I'm really
excited about bees and networks so I'm
really interested both in like the
theoretical side sweep oh yeah I'm so
sorry so I'm I did my masters in a
forestry school and I was in Connecticut
and then before that I was a lot of work
nutrient cycling I don't think so no
where is she based oh okay cool I would
love to meet her that would be hi I'm
Jenny Julie let's meet you um and so I'm
really interested in birds and I've
loved them since I was about 10 years
old that I became interested in them
enemy ecology and evolutionary biology
perspective when I was I'm starting as
an undergraduate at the University of
Chicago so there I worked on
understanding the distribution of
non-native parrots in the US and doing
that species distribution modeling to
understand what environmental factors
influence distribution um so I really
loved that work and I loved thinking
about birds in a wide geographic
distribution manner um but one aspect
that was kind of missing for me there
was understanding how their movement so
for my PhD work I'm really interested in
focusing on movement and social ecology
of birds I'm also really interested in
migration I think it's the coolest thing
and so I'd love to focus on how birds
make decisions about movement and route
as they're migrating I'm currently I'm
doing a gap years I've been learning all
of these different techniques and
ornithology
banding as well as different molecular
techniques so I'm really excited to
apply some of those techniques to my PhD
as well to continue doing some modeling
sounds like that's pretty apparent yeah
what else
so preparation varied what did you think
was good yet cool so yeah knowing what
the context of that research is what
does it matter
yeah yes organizing in a logical way
that's hard to do on your feet but yeah
it matters any other things like
specifics of this yeah cool yeah so when
you're talking it's not just you're
talking to anybody you're talking
specifically to someone that you want to
work with or for and then you really
want to make sure you're telling them
why you're so excited about working with
them or why you're a good fit great
other things that people noticed was
there anything that you're like I think
I might do that maybe okay so I do this
obviously like you can tell I'm like a
little crazy sometimes and so I walk in
and I'm like oh god Birds they're so
cool I'm just like really excited about
that and people are like yeah okay great
the reality is that a lot of us end up
interviewing for grad school because
we're passionate because you are
enthusiastic so you notice when Jenny
talked about her research she still was
like migration so cool it's just the
coolest and that's great you want to be
authentic to who you are so not all of
us are like crazy bouncy balls some of
us like personality very so that's why
I'm weird and I'm up at this front of
the room get really excited not all of
us are that way you don't have to be any
particular way when you're interviewing
people are not judging you based on how
you perform as a person or something
like that they are looking for who you
are in reality so whatever that is do it
you know your self best and you know how
you want to interact with other people
and how you want to build that
relationship because that's what you're
doing is you're figuring out if you're a
good match with these people okay
there's more to talk about we're going
to debrief in small groups but to give
you all sort of some tools as we talked
about for doing your own elevator
pitches
gennadi has handed out this present past
future formula it's a formula it's
simplistic but it helps you to sort of
think about what you might include in
that introduction in the interview so
we're gonna give you five ish minutes
and as you look at this sheet you see on
the front side of it the front side of
it has a lot of questions that might
relate to your present your past and on
the back side there's a blank this is a
gimmicky thing but to help you prep for
your elevator pitch for grad school
we're gonna give you a few minutes to
jot down some experiences that fit in to
present past and future and what
narrative might tie all of those
together the reason you're doing this
now is that you're going to practice
these pitches rapid-fire not stressful
hope probably stressful hopefully not
too
they're taking just a few minutes this
is for your use nobody's looking at it
right something if you want to but start
thinking about what your pitch might be
and then we're gonna actually do them
you're gonna pair off and we'll do them
in a second okay
face something that you thought was
really helpful so here in this debrief
work something that you're still
concerned about and so let's start this
table one of you can use the mic elect
someone yeah no I thought I would
amplify that yeah
the takeaway I had one of the takeaways
I mean there's several was that you have
to remember that you may be really
passionate about stuff that you're
you're also like being interviewed
alongside two other people were also
very passionate about steps so you have
to think how do i express it in a way
that puts me you know makes me stand out
from the pack can be scary but finding
that thing that's like that you care
most about one of the tables we were
talking about the thing that gets you
like really going where you're like yes
this is what I feel comfortable I'm good
and motivated doing that's what you
should talk about so yeah we're
passionate about many things I'm going
to go to your table this is the table we
talked about yeah so just kinda going
off of what she said um a big concern of
mine when I was giving my little speech
or spiel or whatever it is was trying to
tie in you know things that you're
passionate about outside of science is
outside of research and what may be and
how that may have drawn you into
research and kind of you know pushing
you in that direction so it's just good
to know that they're looking at you this
is a conversation this isn't you know
Justin what is what can you bring to
this job you know what can you bring as
a human being and what kind of aspects
to science you know or what kind of
aspects of yourself can you bring sort
of diversify our science knowing this
left
so I think two of the big takeaways here
one was we were talking a little bit
about if you're sort of like jumping
from like one system to another like
somebody here was a doing more cancer
research and I wants to talk about plant
metabolites as long as you can explain
like why and how it's related like
myself personally I was an engineering
undergrad did environmental science now
I'm an agriculture but it's all like
sustainability related so having sort of
like a narrative that makes sense to
like explain why you're interested in
this stuff how you've gotten where you
are everybody's got different paths so
that's important one question that I
told the group about that I always ask
at the end of an interview and they
thought it was all good and wanted me to
share with everybody is I always end it
by saying now that you've had a chance
to talk to me look at my materials and
everything did you have any hesitation
to hiring me and how can I sorta like
clarify things or explain things to you
so that I can like clear that up
and I think it'll be helpful we talked
about a lot of different things but I
think two main things that stood out
where one was what you just said that
people come with a diversity of
experiences and research backgrounds and
how do you kind of tie all of those
things into one single narrative and
should you even do that so how you kind
of visualize your story that way and the
second thing we talked about was you
know in terms of future plans how
specific should you get should you tie
yourself down to one particular career
or what the professor would feel like
you're not a good fit for the lab
because you specific so up in the air
great questions
so like going through this I can just
kind of see that graduate school
interview is kind of really different
from my co-working interview it's very
structured differently so just trying to
get like a feel for a middle ground of
how much do you say how do you stay
focused and what you're going to say
without going or being too broad and
rambling so kind of getting to the point
but also making sure that your point was
me I think for me personally it's like
sometimes I feel like I went to sleep
one day and then woke up where I am so
having to like be able being able to
backtrack and figure out how I actually
got here because especially because I
haven't been like invested in the
sciences my whole life I actually was
more of like an arts and like an English
person so trying to figure out my story
and like the reasons for why I end up
where I am and being able to explain
that to somebody else very quickly is a
bit of an undertaking and I definitely
think I need to I need to think about
that going forward we talked about a
couple strategies as far as keeping calm
keeping your composure during the
interview one of them was looking at
sign language - you know they're they
look calm so you should be calm another
one was you know having some mnemonic
device or some method of figuring out
what you're going to talk about what
points you want ahead and the basically
the main point was as long as you keep
cool and don't freak out you'll be I so
even if you do freak out
I have freaked out in most interviews
I've done whether it was like through
insane excitement or just like horrible
nerves so it's okay they know that
you're interviewing and they know like
you're talking to somebody who did this
actual interview at some point in their
past they may or may not remember
exactly what it was like but they did it
and you know that they want to know
about you you're there because they
wanted to talk to you so if you can for
me I always remind myself I'm like I'm
sitting in this seat because they
me but they wanted to know things about
me I can do this it's going to be okay
and that self-talk does matter for some
more than others yeah this is the time
for you to tell someone else what you're
most excited about and you get to ask
questions so I know some of you talked
about how do you focus your talk how do
you plan for the future if you have
remaining questions about that you can
find any of the grad students who are
here right now and really anyone else
anybody you want to talk to about that
so you're gonna do mock interviews after
lunch but thankfully you have a break
now for lunch they're mock interviews
it's gonna be fun thank you all very
much
we'll see you around this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu